hey leute was glaubt willkommen bei neue
video bevor es mit dem video losgeht
ich lag gestern im bett und hat mir noch
mal so kurz gedanken gemacht zu dem was
gestern passiert es so und ich habe mich
so gefragt warum hast du das gemacht so
ich hab's halt noch mal sorry an alle
man macht fehler es tut mir persönlich
sehr leid dass dass wir das so
durchgeführt haben wie wir es
durchgeführt haben es war eigentlich
dumm so es ist ja klar ist wenn man
sowas auflöst dass es ein fake gering
ist dass man da ein bisschen hält
bekommt ist normal
nämlich an können die gerne machen kein
problem
ich wollte mich wirklich nochmal zu
entschuldigen so war ein fehler wie
gesagt man macht fehler kommt nicht mehr
vor
ich hoffe ihr versteht mich da jetzt ein
bisschen so ich will eigentlich gar
nicht so das war mir schon wirklich so
hab ich auch gestern genannt dieser
content den wir da gemacht haben
da geht schon so ein bisschen so das
niveau sinkt und das will ich eigentlich
nicht will vernünftig videos machen die
cool sind die unterhaltsam sind
sie sollen aber nicht zu sie werden und
auch nicht zu niveaulos das ist gestern
ein bisschen so eingetreten finde ich
deswegen tut mir leid
ja wie gesagt ich hoffe ihr könnt dann
nochmal drüber wechseln an die ein paar
von euch die meisten wenig aber wollte
ich kurz gesagt haben jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video also nochmals zurück intro
wenn das war früher mal so in tritt
auf jeden fall geht es heute um was
wirklich ganz besonderes das hat auch
noch mal krass für gesprächsstoff
gesorgt vielleicht nicht auf dieser
plattform youtube sondern auch instagram
und zwar um dieses bild von mir mein
mysteriöses bild mein mysteriös das bild
von allen bildern die ich hier auf ins
tram gepostet habe so also schaut euch
mal kurz dieses bild an lass es auf euch
wirken und wahrscheinlich denken sich so
die meisten ja gut was soll damit jetzt
sein
jetzt hat es geklingelt da will wieder
irgendeinen unterschrift von mir haben
habe ich aber nicht gemacht so gut wir
machen weiter bereiche ok eine sache ist
vielleicht doch schon etwas komisch
warum ist der rauch droht aber wir
kommen erst mal zu diesen ganzen
theorien die dazu aufgestellt wurden
wirklich ich habe da den größten scheiß
unter gelesen und ich fand's wirklich
witzig so wie man darauf kommt so die
beste theorie
nee die komplett fertig gesagt ich weiß
gar nicht welche theorie so krass absurd
sein sollte also es war auf jeden fall
alle witzig theorie nummer eins ganz
einfach ich habe irgendwas was ich
rauche oder ein roter qualm rauskommt
theorie nummer zwei ich habe den qualm
ganz einfach am computer angemalt oder
auch ganz vielleicht theorie nummer drei
irgendjemand weil ich ja nicht rauche
ich bin absoluter nichtraucher ehrlich
also bin ich ehrlich wirklich warum ich
jetzt mein ohr hat dass ich lüge nicht
alles gut auf jeden fall eben wer stand
hinter mir mit einer der dose und hat
dem display
ich weiß nicht wie aus der dose qualm
rauskommt aber das soll möglich sein
laut diesen kommentaren darunter ach so
und jetzt kommt die theorie die
irgendwie darunter geschrieben habe wo
ich mir dachte alles klar
wo ist jetzt mein handy werden die
fristen des hits wo ist denn jetzt aber
ich hab's gefunden
ach so ja eine theorie war auch noch das
ist ein punk sein sollte aber leute bei
mir hat sich jetzt erstmal ausgeprägt
kommen keine breakbälle nächster zeit
vielleicht in zwei monaten oder so genau
jetzt haltet euch fest und zwar
irgendwer schreibt das ist die so
genannte toni theorie durch feinste
sowie melitta renate sub objekte werden
rote dispo riedel in die oxidation des
luft ragen atmosphären raums der jede
kleinste teilchen verbunden
so entsteht der rote effekt der
wahrscheinlich
einem filter erstellt wurde und dass
hier niemand gelesen hat natürlich hätte
ich daran roten filtern darüber legen
können dann wäre allerdings das ganze
bild ruth hoffmann ich wollte auch halt
mal zeigen was ich kann auch noch andere
sachen außer irgendwie scheiße euch zu
erzählen deswegen haltet euch fest und
staunt so herzlich willkommen hier an
meinem mit professionellen arbeitsplatz
ich sollte ich vielleicht noch mal ist
mir gerade eingefallen hab ich noch gar
nicht gesagt ich sollte euch vielleicht
noch mal kurz erklären wie dieser rauch
aus meinem mund überhaupt rauskommen
kann weil es geht ja nicht einfach so
ich bin allerdings strikter nichtraucher
deswegen haben wir uns für dieses foto
was total genial es überlegt und so
haben wir uns so eine eklige shisha aus
hongkong oder woher kommt keine ahnung
geholt und ich hab da halt ab und zu mal
dran gezogen um als reale fotos
hinzukriegen irgendwie dumm nicht glaubt
nämlich diese shisha ist fünfmal so
schädlich wie 5 packung markenzigaretten
zusammen aber ich bin halt kein raucher
es macht keinen sinn ich war es egal
wir fangen jetzt an ich zeige euch das
kurz ich hab mir gedacht ich mache
dieses foto einfach schnell schwarz weiß
und der rauch wird ein grün dann haben
wir noch mal vielleicht ein anderes
dingsbums hier special effekt kann ich
vielleicht auch noch mal posten
let's go ja das hier ist photoshop wir
machen jetzt erst mal dieses bild
einfach grün weil der rauch soll grün
werden da machen jetzt erstmal das ganze
bild grün so jetzt muss ich mal kurz
gucken wie das denn überhaupt grünen
wird müssen wir mal kurz uns geduld
wahrscheinlich in diese richtung hhl das
ist doch ein geiles grün wollen wir noch
mal hier ein bisschen nähe sah so genau
das grün soll möglichst geil
herausstechen
deswegen sagt und kommt k
geil geil geil geil geil hier haben wir
jetzt dieses bild noch mal das ist weil
das liegt ganz oben drüber ist auch
scheißegal auf jeden fall ist jetzt das
eine bild grün das andere bild ist
normal so das erste bild machen wir
jetzt einfach noch ganz schnell schwarz
weiß
so jetzt haben wir ein schönes schwarz
weiß vielleicht machen wir es schwarz
weiß doch ein bisschen ja wie soll ich
sagen deutlicher krasser so dass man
sich ganz geil auslegen war noch ein
bisschen mehr kontrast drüber dann
sollten da finde ich ein schönes bild
haben was mir persönlich sehr gefällt
und jetzt kommt das wichtigste
jetzt haben wir hier den qualm und
radieren den einfach mal ein bisschen
aus so leute 8 und siehe da siehe da was
ist das denn
was ist das denn der qualm wird einfach
richtig lieber grün ja ich hab das ganze
jetzt ein bisschen ausradiert und siehe
da man muss sich das ganze so vorstellen
das eine bild was unten liegt ist grün
das was darüber liegt ist schwarz weiß
von dem schwarz weißen wieder ein
bisschen wegradiert und dann steht so
was ich bin kein raucher deswegen ihr
könnt euch eure theorien um dieses bild
jetzt sparen
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
auch das kommt jetzt viel spaß ich bin
wieder da ja heute willkommen zurück und
ich weiß ich bin ein ganz schön
kreativer fuchs so ab und zu mal mehr
macht auf jeden fall spaß irgendwas am
computer zu bearbeiten irgendwas cooles
aus dem foto rauszuholen
deswegen habe ich gedacht ihr macht doch
einfach mal den den qualm roth keine
ahnung ob das nicht ich wusste halt vor
wirklich klappt das oder nicht und ich
fand das ergebnis wirklich krass ich
fand es wirklich gut
ja ich hoffe dieses video hat euch
gefallen wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
braucht jetzt nicht mehr über mein foto
philosophieren sondern können erstmal
einfach den daumen nach oben da lassen
müsst ihr nicht aber könnt ihr natürlich
machen denn wie gesagt noch mal kleines
tschuldigung solcher content wird von
mir nicht mehr kommen
ich will meinen krassen content jetzt
weiter durchziehen und ja aber nicht
vergessen nichts dazu verpassen selbst
in server als eingeblendet wir sehen uns
schon morgen wieder
morgen kommt auch mal ein cooles video
morgen 18 uhr oder 19 uhr ich weiß noch
nicht hatte
ich wünsche
doch jetzt bin ich hier gegen gekommen
ich würde noch einen angenehmen abend
peace